Back in June, Rick Cole was sitting in a meeting of the Pasadena Municipal Services Committee in City Hall there. That's about as dull a sentence as you could start a podcast with. But then things happen. Rick's a council member.
And I get a text that I glance at from the police chief to the city council that says, "At 5:30, we're making a public announcement that there will be military exercises in Northeast Pasadena. They will take place at St. Luke Hospital, but do not reveal the location." This is at 5:24, six minutes before the public is to be informed.
So you saw that and you thought what?
Well, I thought, that's really strange.
It's not unprecedented there would be military exercises in a residential area. That happens in America. But still, it's strange when it's your area, with no notice at all. The meeting ends. Rick runs to another event.
Meanwhile, I had told my assistant to post on our Instagram account that this military exercise was happening and to actually identify the location. And she told me, you know, they told us very sternly not to say the location. And I said, the people deserve to know where this is happening.
And did she post the name of the hospital?
She did.
Because you just figured, what are they going to do to me? I'm just going to do this?
Exactly. I mean, that's the way I've lived my life, Ira.
He's got stories. If you ever run into Rick, get him to tell you the one about how he tried to stop Christopher Columbus's great great, great great great, great great great great great, great great great great great, great great great grandson from becoming grand marshal of Pasadena's Rose Parade. But I digress. Anyway, that night in June, he heads over to this hospital, a creepy old building with broken windows and peeling paint. It's been abandoned for years. And, sure enough, sometime around 8:00 PM--
These giant helicopters can be heard in the distance, getting closer and closer. Then they disgorge paratroopers clambering down ropes onto the roof of the hospital. Flashbang grenades are going off. Simulated gunfire is rattling through the neighborhood. I mean, it was jaw dropping.
This is all supposed to end by 8:30, but in fact, it wasn't over until about 2:00 AM. To Rick, this was outrageous. Why do this in a residential neighborhood with no warning, so people had no chance to prepare, maybe go elsewhere for the night, maybe give their pets tranquilizers so they don't freak out? Now people were hearing all the commotion, probably going onto their phones to figure out what was happening. And he thought he needed to jump in and explain.
Councilmember Rick Cole here in front of the former St. Luke's Hospital. As you can hear--
He's in the dark. Explosions are flashing behind him, like he's some sort of suburban war correspondent.
Flashbangs and simulated gunfire going on-- they're going to be going on for the next half an hour, we're told.
I was focused on the fact that I should tell people what's going on, because their dogs are going to bark. Their kids are going to ask questions. And they're going to wonder, why are helicopters descending on Pasadena? Why are they hearing gunfire in the neighborhood?
He'd done videos like this in the past, in the wake of the Eaton Fire last year, letting people know when it was safe to drink the water or eat vegetables from their gardens, that kind of thing.
And this is going to go on for a while. And good luck to the people that have got to get up and go to work tomorrow morning.
[GUNFIRE]
It's funny. The weird thing about this is that it seems like you all were supposed to act like this was not a weird thing to happen.
That's exactly.
Did it make you feel sort of crazy to be told, like, oh, no, this is normal, don't sweat it?
[LAUGHS] I wouldn't say crazy. It infuriated me. We owe, to the people we serve, to treat them with respect and to keep them informed about things that affect them. And this was such a egregious breach of that trust.
Rick couldn't help but notice that nobody in the military seemed to care how everyday citizens were experiencing all this. And as a 73-year-old councilmember, he felt a duty to take what he saw as a more old-fashioned approach and reached, by the way, nearly 8 million people with his videos informing the public, succeeding more than he ever imagined.
Today on our program, we have stories of people who see a future arrive that feels uglier and meaner than the past. And it's not like they can turn that around. It's way too big. But in every story today, there is somebody who takes a stand and tries to clean up the mess that's around them or call attention to that mess and say no.
We have stories today of some very stubborn and idealistic people, from a small town in Maine to a school in Russia. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
It's This American Life, Act One, Closing Time. Sometimes, as things change in a country because of big historic forces, doctors get put in some weird and difficult situations. That's what happened in this first act in Maine, way up north in Aroostook County. That's so far north that the Canadian border is closer than the nearest US city. The local hospital there is Houlton Regional Hospital. And last year, they announced they were going to close their labor and delivery unit, with one month's notice. Even the unit's nurse manager, Heather Quint, had no idea this was actually coming.
It was delivered very abruptly and matter of factly, I guess. This is what's happening. Our birth rates are going down. We can't recruit. It's not, basically, a money-maker. So we're closing. There was no, I'm sorry. We hate to-- it was just very matter of factly.
It is pretty matter-of-fact reality at this point in America, rural hospitals closing. But labor and delivery departments in particular, they've been vanishing in lots of rural areas. And when a community loses a place to have babies, in the first weeks after that happens, that's when you really see what it means in people's lives.
And the story in Maine unfolded just after Houlton Regional Hospital packed up its labor and delivery department, closed the doors there. As that was happening, a woman who lives in the area, named Katie Gowell, was pregnant with her fifth child. This was a low-risk pregnancy. She was planning to give birth at home, just like she'd done with her fourth child. Her family doctor, who was a midwife before she became a doctor, was going to deliver the baby. So that was the plan.
29 days after Houlton closed its labor and delivery department, Katie Gowell went into labor at home. Reporter Elaine Appleton Grant has the story of what happened next. Quick heads up before we start-- some of us here on staff found ourselves thinking about the TV show The Pitt as we were making this story, because there's no way to explain what happened without diving into some very vivid medical details during childbirth. I just want to say, if that's not for you, please know that is part of this story. Here's Elaine Appleton Grant.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I'm like, well, Mom, maybe I shouldn't have called them already, because it was sort of-- I kind of went like a standstill for a while.
But all of a sudden, it was like someone poked me awake. And I sat bolt upright. And I said, what did Katie say? And Katie was down the hallway in the bathroom at that point. So I went down there, and I said, did you say something? And she said, yeah. I said, my water broke.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
And then I just sat there for a few minutes. And so then I'm like, well, I'm going to get up now. And then I went to wipe, and I felt something.
And she said, what's that? And I looked down in the toilet, and there was probably 8 inches of cord hanging out, not quite touching the toilet water, but close. So I was like, immediately, this is very bad. This is a prolapsed cord, which rarely happens. I just said, it looks like the cord. We need to check you out. And let's get in the bed.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
And we got her on the bed. And I was checking to see if she's completely dilated, ready to push the baby out. I thought, it's her fifth baby. I thought, if we could give one push and finish this, I'll do that. But that wasn't the case. She was probably about 6 centimeters.
I was terrified, because I didn't want the baby to die.
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
I turned around. And my nurse has beautiful big, blue eyes. And they always comfort me in the middle of anything. And I turned around, and I looked in her eyes. And I said, call 911. And her eyes went two sizes bigger because she's actually never heard me say that in working with her 12 years. Yeah.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I started to coach her that the life of the baby is at stake, and you're going to have to go through quite a bit if we're going to hope to save your child.
Because me, being in the moment, I don't remember every detail, where she would remember every detail. And I trust her with telling my story. I trust her completely with everything.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I chose what I thought was the best course of action, which-- I gently replaced it into the vagina. Is that OK to say on tape? OK, gently replaced it inside so that the warmth of her body would keep the cord warm, because I knew we're in Maine, and although it was June, it wasn't that warm.
I shifted myself and climbed onto the bed between her legs, crouching, sort of on all fours, kneeling, crouching down.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I was internally inside the patient, pushing upward toward her head as, basically, hard as I could, using two fingers to push up, the rest of my fingers to lightly be touching the cord to keep track of the heart tones at all times. Because if they slowed down, I knew something's pinching. If they slowed down, I also knew I needed to push up higher and get the head up higher.
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
Probably up to my wrist, starting forearm. Meanwhile, Katie's own body wants to push the baby out, right? Contractions push down. So to have my hand, that's painful for her. And I knew it was painful. And I told her, I'm very sorry, but I can't care about your pain. It's a very weird pain. It's a deep pain. Anyone who's had a cervical biopsy, an endometrial biopsy, an IUD put in-- I think it's a pain no one can describe. And then this is times a whole lot more, because there's a baby in there too, and now someone's hand as well.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I said, no, we're not. And they said, well, that's what they're saying. I said, I don't care what they're saying. We are not doing that. You tell them a doctor's on site.
And I said, you call Houlton Regional. You're telling them we're coming. And I mean, we're coming.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I said, Sasha, then get a chainsaw and cut the wall down.
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
He was ready to go get a chainsaw and cut the wall down because they knew I wasn't moving, and I wasn't allowing her to get up. I didn't care if it was EMS and their truck. I was not giving over my place of authority, because I did not see that they had adequate knowledge or understanding of the situation.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
We always count to three, and then we all pull together, like a bunch of he-men. So he's like, who's going to count? And how are we going to do this? Are you going to count? Who's going to count? They just kept on like that. And I looked at my nurse, and I said, you count. So she took over. Like, she heard me say that, and that was it. And I hate to get real loud on this mic, but she proceeded to just roar. We're going to count. 1, 2, 3! And honestly, I think she almost single-handedly pulled me, Katie over to the gurney, with them helping some.
It's a very bumpy road. These are the back roads of the county, right? So potholes, bumps, very curvy. At times, I thought I was going to fall off the gurney. And the paramedic would grab the waistband on the back of my skirt and hold me so I would hold steady. And I needed to hold steady. My hand had to hold steady.
And her leg, at one point, slipped off the gurney and sort of fell down. And so I grabbed her leg and pulled it back up, and I was holding her leg on the gurney with me. So it was a tight squeeze. I was beginning to feel exhausted. I myself don't have the best back, and this was a very awkward position. And your legs are all curled up under you. So you're in an intense kneeling-- sitting on your legs, squatting. So my legs are falling asleep. My hand is starting to fall asleep from the angle that I'm at.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
But my hand would periodically feel like it was completely numb. And I would worry, like, am I going to be pinching this cord? And then it would wake up again intermittently. But it was painful, like when your hand falls asleep and it's very painful. It was becoming physically very painful to continue.
LifeFlight still headed to Houlton Regional?
Correct.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
Yeah. They just started spooling up. I'm looking out my window at them. So yeah. That's our plan.
They are just now leaving the scene, headed to the hospital.
I did not agree with that plan at all, because I knew that I could not take another however many minutes it would take to get into LifeFlight, and them to fuel up, and then to stay like that till a C-section can be done at Eastern Maine Hospital in Bangor. There's just no way.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I think they woke me up from sleep. So it was one of those, like, ring, ring, phone call. What's going on? OK. I'll be there in five minutes.
But I'm here. At that point, I'm like, no, we'll have the baby here. And let's go ahead and call in the OR team, and we should deliver her here. We still have that capability. And everyone at that point was like, oh, yeah, we can do that.
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
Yeah. They didn't even really think about the fact they still had that capability. But at that transition time, they did.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
And so we pulled up at the ambulance entrance, and the obstetrician came outside to meet us, which I was so glad for, and started taking the history from me while we were unloading.
And I was like, hi, I'm Dr. Tschirhart. I'm an OB/GYN. I'm the one on call today. Recommendation is emergency C-section, if it's OK with you. And we're going to roll you right into the operating room and deliver the baby. Dr. Fuchs also was giving me kind of a sign-out about what was happening with her, what her background was, and that she could still feel the cord pulse.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
So we basically put the surgical drapes over the top of Dr. Fuchs, threw the Betadine sterilizing fluid on Katie.
They opened a bottle of iodine and dumped it over her belly, over my top of my arm, my forearm that was near her. So my cheek is laying on Katie's thigh. I have my head sideways, trying to breathe in a little air pocket in this drape. It's a very awkward position, to say the least, for her and me.
We have surgical equipment and tubing and electrocautery and suction kind of sitting on top of Dr. Fuchs, because she's right there between Katie's legs.
I can feel they are putting their tools on my back.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
And nurses sort of scurried about, looking for a Doppler. They either couldn't find one or they didn't have one available, but they had no Doppler anyway. And so I told her, it's OK, because I can feel the heartbeat. And so it had been 120s. But then at one point, while they were still prepping, it went down to, like, 90. And so I called that out to her. I said, so we're down to 90. You all better hurry.
(INTERVIEWER) ELAINE APPLETON
A normal fetal heart rate is 120 to 160. And so we allow a little bit outside that range, but 90 is definitely getting in trouble. It's often the signal that there's an impending disaster. My fear was the next beat was going to be 60 and the next beat nothing. And then I did my usual, which-- I pushed a little harder on the head, tried a little harder to protect the cord, and I felt the heart rate go back up to the 120s. So then I called out again to reassure them, we're back up to the 120. You're OK. We're doing all right.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
As soon as she went to sleep, I made the incision, got down to her uterus.
I could feel them start to cut the skin and the muscle layers to enter the abdomen. And I thought, oh, dear, my fingers are awfully high up there. What if they cut my fingers? I better pull back a little bit at just the right moment, but not too soon to lose the heartbeat. So I withdrew a little bit. And then I could sort of feel them, that they were in the uterus.
And my hand reached down to pull the baby's head out, and our hands touched. So my hand touched Dr. Fuchs's hand as I was lifting the baby's head out of the incision.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I could see her off to my left, when she was getting worked on. And then when I was in the recovery room, she was still getting worked on, because then that's when they put her in their incubator type thing. I still didn't get to hold her.
I cried. I cried. I didn't know at that time-- I didn't know how she was. I didn't get to see her. I didn't get to know anything. And then I just saw them wheel her away. It's just a-- I don't know how to describe-- it's a very hard thing, especially seeing her leave. I don't know. It's just-- it was hard, very hard.
(HOST) ELAINE APPLETON
I wanted to be like-- when they closed it down, I wanted to be like, OK, this is what you guys want? This is what you're going to get. But the nurse in me, the person in me-- that's my patient. Hell, yes, I'm going to be there. I threw on my clothes, and I was there. And I went to Bangor with her. And I sat, and I held her hand, and I talked to her the entire time. So, no. Oh. When I got the call, I wanted to be like, figure it out, but not when my patients are involved. I'm like, yep, I'll be right down.
Elaine Appleton Grant. That story was produced by Lilly Sullivan and edited by Phia Bennin. Elaine originally learned about this story from reporting by Emily Hedegard and Stephanie McFeeters of The Maine Monitor. Coming up, raise your hand if you know what Труд -- дело чести means. That's in a minute, comrades, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "I Couldn't Help but Notice," we have stories where people see a new future arrive, one that is not quite as pleasant as the past. And they can't help themselves. They take action, in some way or another, in their own little corner of the world. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, Conversations About Important Things.
So the documentary that won this year's Academy Award is called Mr. Nobody Against Putin. It was co-directed by a Russian guy and an American, Pasha Talankin and David Borenstein. And it's about the propaganda campaign that was rolled out in Russia after Russia invaded Ukraine in 2022 and the shock of that propaganda push, for one person in particular. If you haven't seen the film, it is really worth seeing. And one of the people on staff here at This American Life, Valerie Kipnis, has watched it four times. She'll tell you why. Here's Val.
Here are some scenes from my family growing up. Someone, let's say my mom, would say this to me. Glory to labor! She'd say it in Russian. Then she'd hand me a broom. Or she'd say, Труд -- дело чести. Labor is a matter of honor. She used to say that on Sunday morning when she woke me up for chores.
These are all propaganda slogans from her upbringing in the Soviet Union. She and my dad both grew up there. My dad would say things like this too. So did my grandmothers. They both live with us. And these lines always got a laugh from each other. Like, my mom would say, Партия -- наш рулевой!. The party is our helmsman. And my grandmother, Bella, would laugh and say, last time I saw that one was on the wall of an auditorium.
Unlike them, I grew up here, which meant I was always behind, always playing catch-up in a household full of inside jokes, always trying to see into this world they had in their heads. I was obsessed with it. So I'd ask the same questions over and over again. And they would answer my questions patiently, kindly, on long car rides, on the subway to school, on our walks near the BQE.
But I kept going. I wanted to understand what it actually felt like to live surrounded by banners and slogans. My grandmother would shrug and say что было, то было. It just was what it was. It didn't feel special to us. We didn't know another version of life. And then she'd call me by my family nickname, почемучка, which means, roughly, "kid who drives us crazy by asking why all the time."
Being a почемучка and all, it's only natural that I watched this new documentary four times-- three times before it won the Oscar, just saying. And the thing I couldn't get enough of was that here was a movie that answered some of the questions I'd been asking for so long. The documentary starts less than a month after Russia invaded Ukraine, the beginning of the full-scale invasion.
And it focuses on one school in one town in Russia as the Ministry of Education rolls out a massive, nationwide propaganda campaign, a new, quote, "patriotic curriculum," which would include new lesson plans for teachers, nationalistic poem recitations for students, mandatory school-wide salutes to the flag, and mandatory lessons called Разговоры о важном. Conversations about Important Things, where teachers are asked to talk about stuff like the importance of war songs or the heroism of Russian fighters.
Also, a single approved set of history textbooks, written by two people closely affiliated with the Kremlin. High-schoolers would start paramilitary training in gym class. And in the school that's in the documentary, one teacher captures how this all plays out, Pasha Talankin. And I called him up.
Here was a person who made a whole film about what it felt like to see slogans in the auditorium, different slogans than the ones my parents and grandparents grew up with-- a very different time-- but with an undeniable similarity. Both then and now, the state had a tight grip on its own people. And here was Pasha, who wasn't just seeing what was happening around him. He wanted the whole world to see what he was seeing.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
This is Pasha. He's got a round, wide-eyed baby face, big glasses. He's an impish kind of person who talks through a smile, like he's in on some joke you don't know about. The school in the film is actually the same school he once attended. And he loves the school, loves his students, loves his grumpy mom. She's the school librarian. And when the film begins, he's the school's event coordinator and videographer. He films the piano recitals, graduations, performances.
And under the brand-new patriotic curriculum at Pasha's school, Pasha was told he now had a brand-new role. He would be filming teachers and students performing the new lessons. He'd be filming the new flag salutes and paramilitary trainings. And he would be sending all of that footage to the government as proof of compliance. I wanted to know what he thought of his new role as he was doing it, how it actually felt. He answered by telling me a story that never made it into the film.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
What was I thinking about when I filmed this? I mean, at first, I was just-- how do you say this in Russia? I started sweating under my visor. I just lost my mind about what was happening. I just totally freaked out.
When I was going to film computer class-- it didn't end up in the final cut-- I asked myself a question.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
Who is that idiot who was going to be watching all this shit? Who is he? Who is that moron? I mean, it should be some sort of paid job, sitting and watching all this shit. They should pay you some money for that, at least a little bit. Anyway, I did this one little bit of trickery, where I left in only the beginning of the class, where the teacher says, hello, kids, and the end, where they say, OK, class is over. But the shot itself went the whole time of the class, 45 minutes. So in the middle, there was just a black screen, as if something had gone wrong with my camera.
And I sent the video in. And I sat there waiting as they looked over the footage. And I kept waiting for them to say, we can't see it. Something went wrong. It's just a black screen. And they didn't give me a single note. And I thought--
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
--holy shit. I'm here not to actually record, but to surveil the teachers. Watch out. We're watching you. We have a camera. Here it is, recording you. And in that moment, I thought, I'm being used.
I'm being used.
He figured, yeah, OK, they were using him. But he was simultaneously and obsessively filming the changes at his school for his own purposes. And the footage that Pasha captured was really eye-opening for me. It answered so many of the questions I'd badgered my family with over the years.
Because the propaganda, as it rolls out, is sort of the opposite of what I'd always imagined it would be, you know, the classic images of state control-- the seamless, crisp obedience, massive signs, arms being raised in unison, echoey speeches delivered to neat rows of thousands of people. Pasha shows scenes that are so intimate and small and messy, a teacher stumbling over new words she's now required to say, denazification, demilitarization.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
He films teenagers, bored out of their minds, staring blindly into space as another teacher tells them--
If you were born in this country and you don't believe we're doing the right thing, then leave. Go to the country that you think is better. Pasha films young kids with these tiny red berets, chanting new slogans in an assembly.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
They're excited, but looking at each other, like, right? We're saying the right thing? The school days in the film look kind of normal in so many ways, despite all the changes. Kids still horse around and tease each other. There are still piano recitals. It's still just school. But Pasha was like the kid in the Emperor's New Clothes. Every change stood out to him. And he couldn't stop talking about it. His own mother was like, of course these things are happening. They've always been this way. Shut up. And he argued with her.
He lived in a sort of continuous state of shock about the war, about the propaganda. And he told me that when the patriotic curriculum started, he kept sort of waiting for the people around him to freak out as much as he was about what they were being asked to do. But most people just went along with it, adapted, or chose to stay quiet. I wondered why he didn't do that. Then, when I talked to him, I got it.
For starters, Pasha and I are almost the same age, in our 30s. And part of why he's so stunned by what's happening is because of the era he grew up in. It was right after the Soviet Union fell apart, but before Vladimir Putin really started consolidating power. So Pasha was raised in this short window of time when students weren't flooded with slogans and propaganda in the schools, when schools were left mostly untouched by the state apparatus, because the state apparatus had fallen apart.
And so what Pasha was seeing was something my parents and grandparents never got to see-- the beginning of a propaganda push in the schools, which meant he understood what his school was losing when it adopted these changes. And he knew what he was personally losing as nationalism became more and more strictly enforced.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
Over and over again in the film, he addresses people in his life in the camera directly. Like, can you believe this? Why is this happening? Potchemy.
He told me that off camera, he had many more exchanges like that, especially with the other teachers.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
The teachers came to me. They said, Pasha, we don't like all this. And then they come into class and started to say what the Ministry of Education had sent over to them.
The teachers are hostages of this system too.
Pasha also saw himself as a hostage. Before the war and the new curriculum, Pasha was the teacher with the Pussy Riot poster on his wall, the cool guy, the weirdo whose office all the theater kids hung out in, the teacher who had different politics than what was on TV every night.
And for a while, even after the war was underway, he was able to continue being that guy. He wore blue and yellow paperclips on his clothing as symbols of support for Ukraine. He hung an image of an anti-war flag in his office, flipped a Russian flag outside the school upside down. One time, he even played Lady Gaga singing "The Star-Spangled Banner" during a flag assembly instead of the Russian national anthem.
In the movie, he does things that I could not believe he was getting away with. In a country that was introducing laws to criminalize things, like even saying that the war was, in fact, a war, how on Earth could he just do these things and not get in trouble?
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
People sort of saw me as--
--a jester, a holy fool. There he goes, walking around, being foolish.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
In Russia, there is this historical tradition that the jester, the holy fool, could speak out, even to the tzar. The lowest level of society, the most seemingly worthless people, they could say exactly what they thought, tell anyone right to their face.
But that didn't mean the tzars would just ignore him forever. When I talked to Pasha about how his constant provoking was playing out in real life, he told me that behind the scenes of making the film, he could feel his status changing from holy fool to persona non grata. This isn't in the film, but at some point, at Pasha's school, compliance started being supervised in person via a new, quote, "advisor on student affairs." And this advisor took a special interest in Pasha.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
This advisor was supposed to monitor student activity on social media, establish contact with them, basically sniff everything out. And so one day, this advisor came to me and said, I'm going to close your little bullshit factory. Your office in other words, right? I'm going to close it. And so I took my door off its hinges and put it in front of her door and said, how are you going to close this bullshit factory if it doesn't have any doors?
But, of course, this performance eventually ended, and I returned the door to its place. But in the meantime, she got really committed to this work of telling the students not to come see me.
And fewer kids were showing up at his office. The domain he'd carved out inside the school-- not just the physical space of his office, but the permission he represented for kids who wanted to joke around, talk freely, ask questions, and for him to be able to do that-- that was being shrunk down to nothing.
When I asked Pasha what this period of his life felt like, he gave me an answer that I can't help but classify as literally the most Russian thing I've ever heard. He said it was like this one painting he loves, Barge Haulers on the Volga, which is an oil-on-canvas painting by Ilya Repin. It depicts 11 men hauling a barge along the banks of a river. These men are at the point of collapse from exhaustion, oppressed by heavy, hot weather, leaning into these big leather straps attached to the boat they're pulling. They're exhausted, covered in dirt.
But among them stands a younger man, whose face is in the path of the sun. He looks in a different direction. He looks up. And his body refuses to pull the boat. He seems to be the only one questioning the work they're being asked to do.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
Like, why are we doing all this? And the rest of them just keep their head down, keep pulling this ship along the Volga--
--as if they don't hear what he's saying.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
It's like you're speaking different languages and you won't understand each other. You don't have points of contact. You don't have common views on basically any questions. You can't discuss issues that demand discussion. They require it, not because you can change something, but because you need to not be alone. You need to speak in order to feel support, to find at least one person that you can talk about this with. But there's no one.
There is one last scene in the film that really got to me. It's so inside in a way that lets you really feel how much has changed in this one school, this one town. Pasha gets invited to this party of a recent graduate, Vanya, who's heading off to the army. It's his going away party. All his friends toast to him and wish him luck in the future. They pose for pictures with Vanya. Instead of "cheese," they say, "army!"
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
Then they take turns shaving his head with a shaver that breaks halfway through the process.
[SHAVER BUZZING]
Pasha takes a turn at shaving Vanya's head. As he does it, he asks, you decided to sign up on your own?
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
Vanya says, didn't have time. They sent for me. Pasha says, why didn't you call me? Vanya sort of shrugs, as if Pasha's question is dumb and annoying. But then, quietly, he mumbles, it just all happened so fast, in a split second. Besides that, it's all laughs and jokes and debauchery. The shaving part is funny. Everyone's kind of wasted.
But then as it gets late, Vanya and his friends start embracing. One guy cries and hugs him, tells him that he really loves him so much, that he won't forget him. He tells him, you're like a brother to me, not by blood, but by soul.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
Vanya doesn't look so brave in the dark. He looks small and scared. His friends also do. And that's when it hit me. Before now, Vanya and the others seem like they maybe believed in this war, like they wouldn't mind going to fight for Russia. But in this moment, it feels like you can see everyone grasp the realness of the thing they'd been saying, and then immediately understand that there was now no turning back, like a joke gone too far. Because at this point, so many Russians have gone to fight this war, and well over 100,000 Ukrainians have been killed in it.
Do people believe the propaganda? I wondered this question over and over again as I was watching. Does Vanya actually believe in the war he's going to fight? Do the teachers believe that Russia is denazifying Ukraine? Do the kids throwing fake grenades believe in the country they are being trained to defend? It's a version of the question I've been asking my family my whole life. But did you believe in the things you were being taught, the things you were doing, the slogans hung up in the gym? Those are the questions they seem the most frustrated by.
It took me asking Pasha to figure out why. When I asked him if the people around him believe in all this, he scoffed at me, the way my grandma does, like, that's a bad question, you dummy journalist. Don't you understand? He told me, it doesn't matter if people believe in it or not. What matters is that they say it, that they hang the slogans, teach the lessons, sing the anthems.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
First, it's a routine that's like, I believe, I don't believe, but I say it.
Then it becomes culture. These lessons are already in the schedule. Everyone's used to it, like, you got to say this. You got to listen to that. You got to raise the flag or whatever else.
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
And then it becomes a cage, and you think this is normal. And I'd also add that the cage actually remains open.
And you can leave it at any moment. But as soon as you do, you realize that everyone else is in the cage. You walk out, and you realize that you've become an outcast, a loner, that your opinion, you, yourself, you don't matter to anyone. And that's also the work of propaganda. That's what it does.
Pasha became more and more isolated, retreated from his friends and family. They stayed away from him too. An unmarked vehicle showed up outside his home. And he got scared and left the country without telling anyone where he was going or why. And he can't go back.
I should probably fess up now and say, all those times I was asking my family about how they felt, growing up, when I was posing those exact questions to Pasha, in the back of my mind, I was always wondering, who would I be if I was put in that situation, what kind of person? Would I be able to see what was happening and push back?
When I saw the film and when I talked to Pasha, I found all these similarities between us. We're both similar ages, similar tendency to ask questions. And I did think-- quietly, to myself-- that had I been put in the situation, I probably would be like Pasha. I told my dad this-- big mistake.
He said, really? You'd be like that? What are you doing right now in this country? There are things happening here that you don't like. Then I said, I'm doing my best, I think. Then he said, well, isn't that great? Your best. What's that got to do with anything?
Valerie Kipnis is one of the producers of our show. The actor who's reading Pasha's quotes in English was E. Lia Kleinbock.
Well, our program was produced today by Nadia Reiman and edited by Nancy Updike. The people who put together today's show include Chana Joffe-Walt, Adriene Lilly, Tobin Low, Molly Marcello, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ruthie Petitto, Ryan Rumery, Ruby Schwartz, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Marisa Robertson-Textor, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman, Senior Editor, David Kestenbaum. Our Executive Editor is Emanuele Berry.
Special thanks today to Emmanuelle Pare, David Borenstein, Katia Kize, Bela Shayevich, Daniel Plyam, Katherine Emery, Ruth and Mark Fitzpatrick, Henry Frank, Chris Lavoie, and Brett Morse. Elaine Appleton Grant's story in Act One was supported by a grant from the National Institute for Health Care Management. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
Special thanks today to This American Life Partners Sean Collins and Stonewall and Traveler Peek. Sean Collins, I know you. We worked together at NPR. Nice to see you here in this ad. How's Oklahoma? They and all of our Life Partners have subscribed to help us keep making our program. When you do that, you get to listen ad free. And you get other stuff, including bonus episodes. Our most recent one that I did with one of my coworkers, Diane Wu, turned out so much more emotional and personal than I think either of us expected.
Anyway, if you want to hear that, you got to join. Go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. That link is also in the show notes. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. His dream job was actually to be on Sesame Street. When he auditioned, he was told his performance was not quite right for children.
We're going to count. 1, 2, 3!
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.